bandit délinquants voyous gangsters est
ce qu'on le devient ou est-ce que c'est
dès la naissance
est-ce qu'on est récupérable ou
irrécupérable avant de répondre enfin de
tenter de répondre à ces questions je
voudrais commencer par parler des
victimes
quand j'ai pas j'ai entendu parler pour
la première fois de la justice
restaurative j'avais déjà travaillé que
des victimes
je m'explique j'intervenais avec stomy
bugzy dans les prisons dans dans les pgi
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse et
on s'est fait une réflexion quasiment en
même temps on s'est dit c'est bien de
donner la parole à tous ces anciens
détenus de devenir expliqué tout tout
tout notre vécu d'essayer de le
rapporter tout un témoignage et surtout
de leur faire comprendre ce que nous on
avait on avait misé un temps à
comprendre mais on s'est dit il manque
une place pour les victimes
et c'est là que tout seul j'ai fait des
recherches j'ai commencéà sur internet
et puis d'une bouche à oreille g et puis
j'ai rencontré des victimes
j'ai rencontré une victime qui s'appelle
mariage qui a été victime d'un braquage
d'un gros braquage il ya 14 ans et un
braquage qui a eu lui même vraiment très
très violent j'ai commencé à lui
expliquer ce qu'on faisait dans les
prisons comme en intervenez dans l'airé
chez les jeunes avec les jeunes et je
lui ai dit que j'essayais d'expliquer
aux jeunes ce que c'était qu'être une
victime mais qu' il n'y avait pas mieux
qu'une victime pour venir le faire à ma
place ou au moins avec moi et elle a
tout de suite dit oui
d'autres victimes avait dit non et je le
respecte des victimes ne voulait pas
intervenir et ça se respecte
mais voilà marie-ange a été notre
première victime et qui est venu avec
nous l'an d'une prison et et qui a
essayé de faire comprendre aux jeunes
aux moins jeunes enfin au moins aux
délinquants aux prisonniers
ce que c'était qu'être une victime et là
il s'est passé quelque chose de magique
vraiment j'ai le souvenir d'un jeune
dire à la victime mais madame nous quand
on cambriole on cambriole votre maison
c'est pas à vous qu'on s'attaque on
s'attaque à votre bien on attend que
vous soyez pas là la lui a répondu vous
savez quand on rentre du travail ou de
vacances et qu'on voit notre maison
cambriolée on est vieux comme si on
était victime d'un viol on dort plus
pareil dans une maison cambriolée
alors imaginez quand c'est un braquage
quand on est traumatisée par des armes
ou quoi et là les jeunes comprenez les
détenus comprenez met donc je voulais
aborder mon tout en parlant d'abord des
victimes pour montrer ce qu'on fait avec
les victimes mais je voulais aussi
surtout revenir vraiment en arrière je
suis david desclos un ancien bandit
j'ai fait dix ans de prison dans ma vie
je viens d'un quartier très pauvre où on
a tous baigné dans la délinquance si on
avait pas un pour rattraper l'autre
un quartier où on avait comme nom la
cité déchets tam alors shitan en
achètent and en arabe c'est les diables
on nous appelait les diables on était
des des fou anarchiste
on pensait que la société n'avait rien
fait pour nous que qu'il ne ferait
jamais rien pour nous que tout ce qu'on
avait appris dans la délinquance c'est à
dire le vol la cambriole le la façon de
se débrouiller pour au début manger
ensuite nous habiller et ensuite la
cambriole comme je les dis on pensait
qu'on était bon qu'à ça qu'on allait
faire que ça de notre vie et donc le
quartier très réputé réputé voilà on tue
rentrer dans le quartier c'était
quartier coupe gorge on était vraiment
anarchistes et on a mal grandi là dedans
on a grandi en pensant qu'on était bon
qu'à ça comme je les lis et puis moi je
me suis très vite spécialisée dans la
neutralisation des systèmes d'alarmé
parce que j'ai eu un déclic
c'est à dire de ne pas m'attaquer au
genre la violence tout ça déjà je
voulais pas je voulais rentrer dans les
lieux sans qu'on me voit rentrer et
ressortir sans qu'on l'ait vu rentrer
avec le pacte avec le contenu du coffre
très vite je me suis attaqué aux banques
et là j'ai eu comme un déclic
surtout en plein tribunal parce que je
me suis fait attraper en sur mon dernier
gros casse en train de creuser un tunnel
dans les égouts jusqu'à une banque
donc je me suis aussi évadés et au bout
d'un an de kabal je me suis rendu en
plein tribunal j'ai eu le déclic j'ai
regardé les juges le procureur les
avocats la presse la salle je me disais
j'avais donné ma vie à ce système
judiciaire c'est comme si mon corps ce
genre enfin c'est comme si je sortais de
mon corps et que je voyais tout ça dans
jeu prenait de la hauteur sur tout ça et
je me suis dit ça avait l'air d'une
pièce de théâtre
ce n'était pas une c'était vraiment la
réalité
je me disais à la fin de ce procès ils
vont tous rentrés chez eux
tout le monde va avoir son argent leur
payent leur petite vie tranquille mais
moi je laissais ma femme ma famille que
je savais que j'allais rendre très
malheureux parce que j'avais déjà fait
deux ans de prison en plusieurs peines
et je savais ce que c'était que les
parloirs de la misère que j'allais faire
de apporter à ma famille est donc dans
ce tribunal je me disais mais david tout
ce culot cette intelligence ce talent
mais parce que voilà jeu pour moi tout
ce qu'on avait appris comment on a
neutralisé un système d'alarmé rentrer
dans une banque
ouvrir les coffres forts au chalumeau
découpeur même la journée quand on
faisait les coffres forts en filouterie
c'est à dire entrer dans une grande
surface chercher la clé du coffre
pendant que les gens font leurs courses
jouer au loup et le personnel ouvrir le
coffre prendre la recette du coffre
toutes ces choses là pour moi je me
disais il faut quand même une certaine
intelligence et un certain culot au
moins un culot je me disais dans ce
tribunal
ils me font passer pour le pire des
gangsters le pire des voyous
irrécupérable parce que j'étais
multirécidiviste donc considérer
irrécupérable je me disais c'est vrai on
peut pas leur donner tort j'avais eu des
sursis et compagnie et tout est là je me
dis s'il savait le culot qu'il faut
c'est un terrain et je me dis mais
pourquoi je l' ai mis là dedans et
toujours en prenant cette hauteur dans
ce tribunal
je me disais moi je vais retourne je
vais je vais rentrer en prison avec huit
ans ferme
huit ans pour sans armes sans violence
même si j'avais je voulais leur
expliquer mes principes je leur ai dit
ok j'ai volé j'ai quand brive et cette
banque mais mais sans arme et sans
violence mon 100 foot et tout ça a été
mis de côté et essayer d'expliquer que
nous dans les quartiers on a quand même
de l'intelligence du culot tout ça ils
s'en foutent et on
tu es pour eux irrécupérable dit on
était parce que j'avais des complices
avec moi et donc là je me suis dit quand
je suis revenu à ma place de conques de
condamner et que je suis parti en prison
je me suis dit il faut faire comprendre
tout ça à ces jeunes il faut qu'on
arrête de mettre notre note culot notre
intelligence dans cette délinquance il
faut qu'on la met dans l'honnêteté dans
les quartiers il ya du lourd
il ya vraiment un gros gros potentiel
quand on on a dealé toute notre enfance
toute notre jeunesse on a dealé on a on
a eu des kilos de shit pour des on a
tenu pour des milliers d'euros vraiment
des milliers et quand tu tiens tout ça
tout ce business c'est voilà c'est comme
on est comme des hommes d'affaires ont
sauf que nous si on se plante il peut y
avoir des règlements de compte qui peut
et c'est très très chaud alors que les
hommes d'affaires s'il se plante bombe
rr commencé ils gardent leur santé et
leur liberté et tout ça moi j'étais en
train de comprendre tout ça je me disais
il ya vraiment un potentiel il faut
faire comprendre et c'est là que en
promenade j'ai commencé à essayer
d'expliquer aux jeunes mais j'étais pas
écouté j'étais dans le même été je livre
enfin je les voyais comme eux ils comme
comme moi j'étais à l'époque c'est à
dire si on venait me faire la morale
j'arrive à faire la morale à quelqu'un
d'autre j'étais dans mon truc dans mon
trip je savais que c'était pas en étant
moralisateurs qui est que tu allais
faire avec j'allais faire comprendre les
choses
et donc j'ai commencé à le faire en y
mettant des pointes d'humour je rigolais
je racontais mon évasion je racontais ma
cavale je racontais comment jeux
dévalisé les coffres je raconte est là
dans la promenade c'est long une
promenade même si c'est qu'une heure
mais quand t'as rien à faire le gris de
la ctc du globe et là je faisais rire
tout le monde ils ont émis la promenade
du comedy club
tout le monde me demander une autre une
autre une autre histoire des fois
j'avais pas le temps fin de promenade il
fallait qu'on rentre en cellule le
lendemain on recommençait mais là je
voyais j'étais pris comme un exemple
mais petit à petit j'en voyais mes
messages subtils c'est à dire comme je
le répète et je le répète ne pas mettre
son culot son intelligence son talent
dans dents dans cette malhonnêteté faire
comprendre qu'on est intelligent qu'on a
de l'intelligence et qu'on le gars
chemin mauvais escient c'est à dire
quand
quand tu quand tu fais un coffre fort tu
prends une grosse somme sans armes sans
violence en filouterie comme ça que tu
arrives à sortir tu es fier de toi mais
là tu dis t'as foutu cette intelligence
dans le mauvais côté de la barrière et
donc c'est c'est en leur faisant
comprendre ça et ensuite faire un petit
débat avec eux
leur faisant comprendre que on avait un
[ __ ] de potentiel excusez moi du gros
mot mais un gros potentiel dans les
quartiers et là je voyais la magie
opérer il était d'accord avec moi et
donc je leur disais les gars c'est pas
foutu moi j'ai mis vingt ans à
comprendre ce que vous êtes en train de
comprendre
vous avez quatre mois cinq mois simon à
faire moi j'ai 8 ans il y en a d'autres
qu'on plus
n'attendez pas n'attendez pas d'avoir
des années de prison ce que vous avez
compris mettez le bon escient votre
intelligence votre culot votre talent
allait le mettre dans l'honnêteté vous
allez tout déchirer et là il me disait
oui tu as raison david tu as raison j'ai
dit oui
ne pas mettre sa santé en péril autant
que sa liberté c'est les deux piliers de
base pour réussir dans la vie
et là je me suis dit ce que je faisais
dans la promenade c'était énorme
mais je me suis dit il faut le faire
aussi d'heure pas attendre que ces
jeunes arrivent en prison
et donc là j'ai commencé à écrire un
spectacle tout ce que j'avais mis
imagine fait dans cette promenade gelé
mis sur sur papier je suis sorti et là
j'ai fait l'été les scènes ouvertes
or les professionnels au début avec cinq
minutes de scène il me disait il et fou
il n'arrivait pas à voir où était mon
message et où il racontait une évasion
sur scène racontée comme enjeu
cambrioler une banque
c'était à la clochette à l'époque où des
tentes ont d'ailleurs clochette fallait
partir je l'entendais j'ai vite j'ai
souvent entendu la clochette j'allais
les voir mais le public lui deminor
laisser le raconter ils étaient
intéressés
j'allais voir les points se dit pourquoi
tu as fait sonner la cloche est il
mettait un fou raconter ça sur scène
mais c'est inimaginable 10 millions
message derrière lire un message et il
voulait pas entendre
mais j'ai continué mais j'ai continué
j'ai continué j'ai persévéré et j'ai
gagné un concours et là j'ai eu le droit
de faire mon spectacle en entier
et là ils ont compris des professeurs
sont venus me voir en disant david
excuses nous on n'avait pas qu'on
n'avait pas compris métal times bonne
méthode ça peut aller loin ce que tu
fais et là j'ai rencontré stomy bugzy
j'ai rencontré j'ai fait venir des
jeunes en fin d'études des membres du
ministère de la justice on fait venir
des jeunes au théâtre
et là c'était magnifique les jeunes
comprenez il venait me voir merci et là
on sentait qu'on compte qu'on est en
train de faire quelque chose de fort
avec stomy bugzy qui m'a aidé à la
réécriture à la mise en scène ça a pris
une forme de dengue
ensuite on a été jouée carrément dans
les quartiers on était appelé dans les
quartiers on a même été appelé dans les
prisons
le spectacle les crocs et de rires
étaient été appelés dans les prisons las
j'allais même dans les prisons où
j'avais été incarcéré je retrouvais
d'épée des surveillants qui m'ont
surveillé et qui venaient me voir et qui
me féliciter mais là c'était énorme
et désolé je reviens sur celle ci est
donc là je me suis dit oui oui on peut
être récupérable oui c'est pas foutu je
les dis dès le début est-ce qu'on est
voyou bandits ou gangster dès la
naissance
ou est ce qu'on le devient est-ce qu'on
est récupérable ou irrécupérables et ben
alors d'aujourd'hui je peux le dire j'en
ai la preuve j'en ai la preuve c'est pas
foutu on peut être récupérable les
messages passent avec humour avec
dérision et là on envoie les messages
les jeunes m'écoute des prisonniers des
délinquants des jalles et dans dpj des
protections richard de la jeunesse les
éducateurs venait me voir en me disant
tu sais va y avoir des jeunes au premier
rang t'étonne post6 lève pas ce qu'ils
sont vraiment ils sont humains et
remettez qui l'écoutent pas y rester non
seulement toute la durée du spectacle
mais en plus c'est eux qui participent
aux débats qui pot qui posais les poils
les premières questions et il n'aime
voir à la fin il me disait david tu m'as
fait comprendre
donc oui même les plus virulents même
ceux que vous voyez à la télé qui casse
tout qui brûle tout même mais on peut
les sauver
personne n'était n'est personne n'est
irrécupérable j'en suis la preuve
parce que je peux vous dire que j'étais
vraiment un sacré cas est ce que le
résultat qu'on a de ce qu'on est en
train de faire est tout simplement
énorme
voilà j'étais c'était david desclos et à
bientôt merci
[Applaudissements]